Pourquoi voter pour la lanceurale ?
Vous avez fait
confiance et vous avez des idées politiques depuis
toujours, tous autant que nous sommes.
Que vous soyez pêcheurs, que vous soyez chasseurs,
que vous soyez passionnés de taureau machis,
que vous aimiez l'équitation,
que vous vouliez encore manger de la viande sur votre
barbecue, est-ce que vous aurez encore la
possibilité de
transmettre à vos enfants et à vos petits-enfants
ce que vos parents
et vos grands-parents vous ont donné ?
Et ben oui, il y a 1 solution
qui passe au-dessus de toutes les idées politiques,
qui vient dans votre ADN,
qui est votre mode de vie.
Votre vie quotidienne
s'est incarnée par l'alliance orale.
Suivez-nous, vous ne serez jamais déçu.
Nous ne sommes pas des gens de compromis
et encore moins des gens de
compromisions.
L'alliance oral,
c'est vous et rien que pour vous !